Speaker 1: I told you recently that it was
a really bad launch for CNN.
Plus, CNN Plus is the streaming wing of CNN
under 10000 viewers a day.
The David Pakman show is dramatically bigger
than CNN Plus, and they spent is it tens or
is it hundreds of millions of dollars on it?
It's crazy.
And just like that, CNN Plus is shutting down
not even a month in Warner Brothers.
Discovery is shutting down CNN Plus as of
April 30, marking one of the company's first
significant maneuvers since completing the
merger of WarnerMedia and Discovery less than
two weeks ago.
This puts an end to CNN Plus.
This decision is in line with AWB, these broader
direct to consumer strategy, said Chris Licht,
the incoming CEO of CNN.
In a complex streaming market, consumers want
simplicity and an all in service, which provides
a better experience and more value than standalone
offerings.
I don't think that's the case.
I talked about this on a stream.
We let a little old us and our colleagues
in independent, progressive media.
We are not part of a network.
We are not part of a coordinated marketing
strategy.
And yet we have plenty of both audience that
is larger than CNN Plus and audience crossover.
The fact that if people want to watch me and
then Sam Cedar and then the young Turks and
you know, whatever else, right, where you
can find us on YouTube, we have YouTube channels,
but you know, our podcasts are in different
places.
We have all different schedules.
When you call in is completely different.
And people watch all of the shows.
They don't they don't need everything to be
an all in all in one solution.
And I think what the problem is that CNN Plus
tried to capitalize generally on the growth
of streaming, which may no longer be growing.
I mean, consider that Netflix saw a loss of
subscribers for the first time in history
that we may be reaching saturation at this
point in time.
But CNN Plus wanted to jump in generally on
the popularity of streaming, but they weren't
bringing known content in the sense of like
Netflix and Amazon Prime, at least.
You go, Oh, here's 10 shows I love.
I already love them.
They're all there with CNN.
Plus, it was original content on a platform
that nobody had any emotional connection to.
Not that everybody's emotional connection
to me is so positive, right?
We have a lot of haters.
But the idea here is, well, people are in
the audience because they want to hear from
me, our team, us, our guests, the callers,
the community.
There was absolutely no community aspect to
CNN.
Plus the technology wasn't innovative or notable.
It's just that it's just a dud.
There's no other way to say it, and we'll
see if some of these other services end up
going the same way.
It doesn't bring me pleasure, but it makes
me reassured that it is not a clear, you know,
everybody likes to have a hot take about what
the Futurists early on the legacy TV people
were saying.
This streaming thing is not going to take
off.
Well, they were wrong.
Then the screaming people said we're going
to have indefinite growth and first mover
advantage will prevent Netflix and Amazon
Prime for ever having any issues.
And growth started slowing down and competitors
entered the market.
And you've got Apple TV with Ben Stiller's
great show and you know, all these different
things.
And so actually, they were wrong, too.
There's no one path forward, and I think the
takeaways are flexibility.
Genuine content and putting the connection
with the audience.
Ideally first, rather than saying we're CNN,
we'll just put a plus sign after it and people
want ran will want random shows.
Our friend Rex Chapman, former NBA player
he had.
I hope that I'm right.
He had or might continue to have.
I don't know.
I saw some of what he was doing on CNN.
Plus it's cool, but I already know Rex.
And so that's the advantage.
And everything about it was approached in
a way that that didn't really make sense.
And it's over.
It's already being shut down April 30th and
think of the money that was spent.
And again, I've said this before, if we got
a cash infusion, that was just five percent
of what was spent on CNN Plus.
We.
10X what we're doing, I mean, we take the
content that we've developed over time, which
we know has led to a decade of growth rate.
We've never had a year where we shrink.
We every year we grow more than a decade,
15 years.
And we just dump that content in front of
tons of people by buying Google ads and YouTube
ads and Twitter ads and all this different
stuff.
We we don't try to reinvent the wheel, we
just say, let's put what we're already doing
that works in front of more people.
And it would have been money much better spent
giving us five percent of what it cost to
launch CNN Plus would have been a much, a
much better investment.
Let me know your thoughts about the new streaming
wars, the at least temporary decline of Netflix.
The end of CNN, plus all of it.
Find me on Twitter at De Packman.
The David Pakman Show is, of course, a viewer
and listener, community supported program,
we don't have a money tree, we don't have
a coin plant in the backyard or anything like
it.
We depend on you and you can sign up at join
Packman dot com.
You can also, if you have a membership already,
you can now gift a membership to somebody
else.
There is a box that you will see that says,
Is this a gift?
And if the answer is yes, you just check the
box if you don'